The things that we think we should care about...
...are not always the same as the things that we actually care about.
That's okay.
I can honestly say that I don't care what the people that I went to high school...
...think about me and that's not going to change.
So, guess what?
I don't follow any of them on social media.
By the way, I just want to mention that when I did this,...
...I was shocked to find that I was following all kinds of people,...
...and brands, and accounts that had absolutely no importance to me.
That's because I've evolved, and changed over time, right?
As we all do.
I also want to challenge you to think critically if something motivates or inspires you.
These are words that are thrown out a lot,...
...but I think that there's a lot of psychology at play in social media, right?
If you're following an account,...
...that in reality actually gives you kind of a sinking feeling,...
...that makes you feel, you know, like a failure,...
...or that you're not doing enough in life,...
...you know, then maybe it's not a good idea to follow that account.